بخموت الجبهه التي عادت ليشتعل رمادها بعد
اكثر من شهر من اعلان مجموعه فاغنر
والقوات الروسيه السيطرتها عليها اللواء
الثالث في الجيش الاوكراني نشر صورا قال
انها من معارك جنوبيه المدينه بين
الجانبين من مسافات قريبه وجدد قال انها
لجنود روس بينما نشرت قوه حرس الحدود
الاوكرانيه مشاهد من مقاله انها معارك
عنيفه ضد القوات الروسيه في باخموت 17
اشتباكا قتاليا وفق المتحدث باسم قياده
عمليات منطقه الشرق في القوه الاوكرانيه
في اتجاه المدينه خلال 24 ساعه ادت الى
مقتل العشره من الجنود الروس وتدمير اليات
ومنصه اطلاق الصواريخ
واضافه الى بخموت قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قوتها وصلت عمليتها
الهجوميه في اتجاهات بريديان
وحققت تقدما في عدد من الجبهات بينما تركز
الهجوم الروسي خصوصا على محوري
حيث دارت اشتباكات وقصف متبادل في مناطق
عديده ودوت انفجارات في مدينه كرامات عقب
رسلي تحليق صواريخ وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بالمقابل تحدثت عن صد قواتها عشر هجمات في
دنياتك ودمرت مستودع ذخيره للقوه
الاوكرانيه في افديفكا كما اسقطت سته
تعرضت بدورها لعمليه قصف صاروخي وفق
السلطات الاوكرانيه ثلاث منها كانت
بصواريخ من طراز اس 300 استهدفت منطقه
دروسكوفكا ولان نال دنيا
المتلاحقه حصه الاسد من المواجهات فخرسون
في الجنوب استهدفت بدورها بقصف اوكراني
طالب 5
سلطته المواليه لروسيا تحدثت بدورها عن
وجود معارك على جبهتها مشكله الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم واصطام
خاوي في السلطات
الاوكرانيه مما سمته هجوما ارهابيا محتملا
في محطه
وغير بعيد اعلن مسؤول شبه جزيره القرم
التي ضمتها روسيا تعرض خطوط السكك الحديد
للاضرار في منطقه كروسكي من دون ان يسقط
ضحايا فكما يجري على جبهات اوكرانيا
الشرقيه والجنوبيه اما في مكان اخر فوق
بحر البلطيق فتدريبات تكتيكيه بطائره
مقاتله لاختبار الجاهزيه لاداء العمليات
القتاليه على مدار الساعه وفق دفاع
الروسيه ولحراسه المجال الجوي
وتلك تبدو رساله روسيه على ان عينها يقظه
ومستعده للتعامل مع اي طارئ رغم انشغالها
بجبهات اوكرانيا وتداعيات التمرد مجموعه
فاجنر